Hello everybody.
I hope everybody is good and having a wonderful weekend.
Um, so if you don't know,
let me tell you,
um, it's currently the I. E. C, um,
voting registration weekend for the 2024 national votes.
If you haven't registered yet,
it's not too late.
Don't despair.
You can still do it
tomorrow from 8 to 5 at your nearest voting station.
To come to my voting station,
I will be at Lower School
Westwood in Boksburg tomorrow from 8 till 5.
Can come through,
come register,
check your status or just come say hi.
Maybe you might even grab yourself Yana, who knows?
Anyway, guys, um,
let's do the right thing.
Let's register.
Um, go out to our numbers and vote and make a difference.
I mean, let your voice be heard.
Love you all and stay proud of South African.